.
WE WILL LAST NIGHT GOOD LUCK.
>> Sean: THANKS, TUCKER.
WELCOME TO "HANNITY."
ALL RIGHT, MERRICK'S ENEMIES,
THEY ARE TESTING JOE BIDEN.
AS PER USUAL, HE ASKED YOU A
VERY FRAIL, WEAK, COGNITIVELY
STRUGGLING COMMANDER IN CHIEF.
IT DOESN'T SEEM LIKE HE IS UP TO
THIS TASK.
WHILE SIPPY CUP JOE IS ENJOYING
A RESTFUL MIDWEEK GETAWAY AT HIS
BEACH HOUSE IN DELAWARE,
AMERICA'S FOOD COSTS ARE NOW
SOARING.
WHY?
BECAUSE OF ANOTHER RATION-BASED
CYBERSECURITY ATTACK.
MEANWHILE, CHINA IS NOW
THREATENING, GET THIS, AN
ALL-OUT NUCLEAR WAR.
AND THEY ARE NOW ALLEGEDLY
EXPANDING THEIR NUCLEAR ARSENAL
IN PREPARATION FOR WHAT THEY SEE
AS AN INTENSE SHOWDOWN WITH
UNITED STATES OF AMERICA.
NOW THIS, OF COURSE AFTER THE
WORLD WAS FINALLY RECOVERING
FROM A PANDEMIC THAT CHINA
DEFINITELY CAUSED.
THEY DIDN'T PROTECT THEIR OWN
COUNTRY WITH A TRAVEL BAN.
CONANT TRAVEL OUT OF WUHAN,
CHINA.
KONA TRAVEL FROM OTHER PARTS OF
CHINA TO WUHAN PROVINCE.
BUT YOU COULD LEAVE WUHAN
PROVINCE AND GO TO THE REST OF
THE WORLD.
OF COURSE, THIS DEADLY DISEASE
LIKELY ORIGINATED, AS WE ARE NOW
DISCOVERING FROM THIS LAB, THE
WUHAN VIROLOGY LAB.
NEARLY 600,000 AMERICANS ARE
DEAD BECAUSE OF, YES, WHAT CHINA
DID AND HOW THEY HANDLED IT.
MILLIONS MORE AROUND THE GLOBE
ARE DEAD BECAUSE OF WHAT CHINA
DID HERE AND DIDN'T DO HERE.
EVERYONE'S LIFE WAS ENDED FOR
MORE THAN A YEAR THANKS TO THE
COMMUNIST CHINESE GOVERNMENT.
HOSTILE ACTORS, A HOSTILE
REGIME, A HOSTILE PRESIDENT,
PRESIDENT G.
NOT ONLY DID THEY PROBABLY
CREATE THE VIRUS, AND AS WE CALL
RELEASE IT INTO THE WORLD.
BUT THEN THEY TRIED TO COVER IT
UP WITH THE HELP OF THE WORLD
HEALTH ORGANIZATION THAT YOU
HELPED FUND.
HOW NICE.
THE MALIGNANT GOVERNMENT OF
CHINA MUST BE HELD ACCOUNTABLE.
SIPPY CUP JOE, YOUR PRESIDENT
DOESN'T SEEM TO WHILE DOING
ANYTHING.
A GOOD FIRST STEP FOR THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION WOULD BE A LITTLE
STRAIGHTFORWARD HONESTY ABOUT
THE ORIGINS OF COVID-19.
BUT IN ORDER FOR THAT TO HAPPEN,
WELL, FIRST, THAT GUY,
DR. ANTHONY FAUCI, THE SO
BELOVED EXPERT, HE NOW NEEDS TO
BE FIRED IMMEDIATELY.
NOW, FOUR MONTHS AT THE START OF
THIS PANDEMIC, WE GAVE DR. FAUCI
THE BENEFIT OF THE DOUBT.
WE HAD HIM ON THE SHOW.
RADIO AND TV.
WE LISTENED TO HIS ADVICE.
BUT AFTER MONTHS OF SERIOUS
MISCALCULATIONS, FLIP-FLOPS,
CRUISE SHIPS, MASKS, LOCKDOWNS,
THE ORIGINS OF COVID-19, THE
MODELS, PROJECTIONS, EVERYTHING
WAS WRONG.
WHILE RIGHTLY NOW, OUR TRUST IN
DR. FLIP FLOP BOW SHE IS
NONEXISTENT.
HE IS APPARENTLY WRITING A BOOK
AND MAKING MONEY.
WE WILL HAVE MORE ON THAT IN A
MOMENT.
THANKS TO THE FREEDOM OF
INFORMATION ACT OR REQUEST, A
TROVE OF NEWLY RELEASED EMAILS
PAINTING A PICTURE OF THE
HIGHEST-PAID BUREAUCRAT.
THAT'S FAUCI.
IN ONE EMAIL, JANUARY 31ST,
2020, ONLY TEN DAYS AFTER THE
FIRST KNOWN CASE OF CORONAVIRUS
IN THE U.S., A TEAM OF AMERICA'S
TOP SCIENTISTS STUDYING
COVID-19, THEY WARNED DR. FAUCI
DIRECTLY THAT "SOME OF THE
FEATURES OF THE VIRUS LOOK
ENGINEERED.
THIS IS TEN DAYS AFTER THE FIRST
IDENTIFIED CASE IN THIS COUNTRY.
THE EXACT DAY THAT DONALD TRUMP
PUT THAT XENOPHOBIC HYSTERICAL
TRAVEL BAN INTO EFFECT.
ONE DAY LATER, FAUCI, OUR TOP
DEPUTY AT THE NATIONAL
INSTITUTES OF HEALTH EXCHANGED
FRANTIC EMAILS ABOUT WHAT WE NOW
KNOW TO BE GAIN OF FUNCTION
RESEARCH.
NOW FOR REFERENCE, GAIN OF
FUNCTION, IF YOU DON'T KNOW,
THAT RESEARCH OFTEN INVOLVES
MANIPULATING VIRUSES FOR THE
PURPOSE OF MAKING THEM MORE
DANGEROUS, MORE INFECTIOUS, AND
MORE LETHAL.
THE PRACTICE IS SO RISKY THAT IT
WAS ACTUALLY TEMPORARILY HALTED
BY OUR GOVERNMENT FROM 2014-'17.
ACCORDING TO FAUCI'S EMAILS, IT
APPEARS THAT THE DOCTOR WAS NOT
ONLY WORRIED THAT THE VIRUS WAS
A RESULT OF GAIN OF FUNCTION
RESEARCH, BUT ALSO THAT HIS NIH
THAT YOU THE TAXPAYERS COULD
HAVE FUNDED, ONE EMAIL TO FAUCI
READS "THE PAPER YOU SENT ME
SAYS THE EXPERIMENTS WERE
PERFORMED BEFORE THE GAIN OF
FUNCTION PAUSE, BUT HAVE SINCE
BEEN REVIEWED AND APPROVED BY
THE NIH."
SOMEONE AT THE NIH WILL TRY TO
DETERMINE IF WE HAVE ANY DISTANT
TIES TO THIS WORK ABROAD.
YEAH, YOU GAVE HIM MONEY.
BUT IN THE FOLLOWING WEEKS,
FAUCI THREW COLD WATER ON THE
THEORY THAT COVID ORIGINATED IN
THIS WUHAN LAB.
IN OTHER WORDS, IT KIND OF READS
TO ME LIKE FAUCI POSSIBLY NEW
DAMN WELL THAT THE U.S. COULD
HAVE HELPED FUND THIS.
IT SEEMED LIKE HE WANTED TO
COVER IT UP.
IN MAY, HE TOLD
"NATIONAL GEOGRAPHIC" THAT HE IS
VERY, VERY STRONGLY LEANING
TOWARD A CONCLUSION THAT THE
VIRUS COULD NOT HAVE BEEN
ARTIFICIALLY OR DELIBERATELY
MANIPULATED.
WRONG AGAIN.
ON MULTIPLE OCCASIONS, FAUCI
STRONGLY IMPLIED THAT THE VIRUS
ORIGINATED IN NATURE.
AND IN AN EMAIL TO DR. FAUCI IN
APRIL, THE NIH DIRECTOR, FRANCIS
COLLINS REFERRED TO THE LAB LEAK
THEORY AS A FOX NEWS-FUELED
CONSPIRACY THEORY THAT HAS GONE
MAINSTREAM.
IN THE SAME MONTH, THE SCIENTIST
NAMED PETER DAWES ACT PROFUSELY
THANKED HIM IN AN EMAIL SAYING I
WANT TO SAY A PERSONAL THANK YOU
FOR STANDING UP AND STATING THAT
THE SCIENTIFIC EVIDENCE REPORT
FROM BACK TO HUMAN SPILLOVER,
NOT A LAB RELEASED IN THE
INSTITUTE OF VIROLOGY.
HE CONTINUED, FROM MY
PERSPECTIVE, YOUR COMMENTS ARE
BRAVE AND COMING FROM YOUR
TRUSTED VOICE WILL HELP DISPEL
THE MYTHS BEING SPUN AROUND THE
VIRUS' ORIGINS.
NOW, HE HAS DEEP TIES TO CHINA,
AND OF COURSE THE WORLD HEALTH
ORGANIZATION THAT YOU PAY FOR
AND HIS NONPROFIT HELPED STEER
NIH GRANTS TO THE WUHAN
INSTITUTE OF VIROLOGY.
SO LET ME MAKE THIS EASY.
LET ME BREAK IT DOWN.
MILLIONS OF YOUR TAX DOLLARS
ENDED UP AT THE WUHAN INSTITUTE
OF VIROLOGY BETWEEN 2014 AND
2019 WHEN GAIN OF FUNCTION
RESEARCH ON CORONA VIRUSES WERE
TAKING PLACE.
IN OTHER WORDS, THE LAB THAT
PROBABLY CREATED AND LEAKED THIS
VIRUS.
2012, FAUCI EVEN SAID, OH, YEAH,
IT'S DANGEROUS, BUT IT IS
CERTAINLY WORTH THE RISK TO DO
GAIN OF FUNCTION RESEARCH.
BUT THE REAL QUESTION TONIGHT IS
WHAT DID DR. FAUCI KNOW?
WHEN DID DR. FAUCI KNOW IT?
AND WAS HE ENGAGED IN SOME TYPE
OF SCIENTIFIC COVER-UP?
IF NOT, THEN WHY WAS AMERICA'S
TOP INFECTIOUS DISEASE EXPERT SO
WRONG FOR SO MANY MONTHS?
AND OF COURSE, AS WE MENTIONED,
JUST LIKE ANDREW CUOMO,
DR. FLIP-FLOP WHILE SHE IS
TRYING TO PROFIT FROM THE
PANDEMIC IN A BOOK HILARIOUSLY
TITLED "EXPECT THE UNINSPECTED.
THANKFULLY, THE BOOK IS ONLY 80
PAGES LONG.
SO JOE BIDEN DIDN'T CARE TO
COMMENT.
YOU STILL HAVE ALL THAT GREAT
FAITH AND CONFIDENCE IN
DR. FAUCI.
I WILL DO IT IF DR. FAUCI SAYS
SO, YOU KEPT TELLING US.
I HATE TO TELL YOU, JOY, I KNOW
YOU ARE ASLEEP RIGHT NOW.
I KNOW YOU HAVE HAD YOUR WARM
MILK AND YOUR LITTLE SIPPY CUP.
PRESIDENTIAL LABEL AND
EVERYTHING.
BUT WE THE AMERICAN PEOPLE DO